what do you got for me a few months ago
someone came into my life i've kind of
had him on the back burner she has a
daughter she has tattoos but this woman
has just stuck with me even though i've
kind of been pushing her away and i'm
kind of not sure what to do you know so
what this is really about is you're
looking for a richest blessing to date a
single mommy um man yeah
i guess i guess yeah in a way man look
man you read my book i have an entire
chapter on dating single moms so it's
not like you're marching into a
slaughterhouse with your eyes closed you
know exactly what you're walking into
you're gonna do what you're gonna do
anyway right like yeah my advice to guys
is you know still the same women without
kids are still a far better choice i get
that you're 37 or whatever it happens to
be and you want to have kids and you you
know tripped across this unicorn i'm
doing anything you know quotation marks
that's your call dude but you're still
gonna invite all the levels of
complexity into your life raising some
other dude's seat and you're never gonna
be able to get rid of that like that's
always gonna have to be a part of your
life i mean if you can live with that
and you're cool with that you do you but
my advice to guys still stays the same